monsieur lindon jour merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france alors on le
voit ce n'est pas un problème de demande
puisque des milliers de personnes se
soient inscrits 1 pour proposer leurs
services aux agriculteurs c'est un
véritable problème d'offre
comment expliquer ce peu d'offres alors
que le secteur a besoin de cette main
d'oeuvre
comment expliquer c'est tout simple
parce qu'en fait tout a été désorganisée
caravelle arrivée du confinement et
notamment pour les produits frais et le
temps il trop frais et dans cette main
d'oeuvre d'habitude sur une main
d'oeuvre qualifiée qui viennent des pays
de l'est et ou qui vient aussi de
l'espagne ou du portugal et ce sont des
gens qui sont payés au rendement
donc ils ont une capacité de travail qui
est quand même pour des travaux qui sont
difficiles qui était assez élevé et
qu'ils sont habitués à ces travaux là et
qui reste plusieurs semaines sur les
exploitations
là on a ouvert avec donc quand on a
besoin d'environ 600 mille travailleurs
salariés dans temporaire dans
l'agriculture et sursis 5000 l'état à
l'estimé dit guillaume a dit qu'il
fallait en trouver deux cent mille en ce
moment puisque les frontières sont
fermées il l'a fait avec son syndicat
d'état qu'on appelle l'affairé soit
parce qu'en fait ils ont monté oui si
farm samba sall fera prendre soin de
savoir vraiment la réalité sur le
terrain
alors déjà se sont portés volontaires
oui bien sûr
240 millions signé mais après quand on
voit les envoyer qu'ils peuvent se
déplacer de maximum 30 kilomètres qu'ils
ne seront pas nourris qu'ils ne seront
pas logés et que certains cas qui sont
arrivés ne ne sont pas trop le travail
difficile bien sûr que aujourd'hui
qu'est ce qui se passe sur le terrain
c'est que une grosse partie des
productions plein champ ne sont pas
ramassées et que bien sûr on à la
plateforme avait des gens qui disent
qu'ils veulent travailler mais en fait
le trait ce travail ne correspond pas à
leurs attentes
sachant aussi qu'il ya des gens qui sont
venus quand même travailler mais qui
quand ledit confinement va être arrivée
au sommet vont repartir et donc comment
vont faire les agriculteurs
le problème c'est qu'en face à ça on se
retrouve non avec des coûts de
production à être est retirée très bas
et que l'allemagne et l'autriche ont
rentré 80000 déjà travailleurs roumains
qui vont travailler dans des grands de
fermes et qu'est ce qu'on va voir
rapidement sur nos étals des fraises des
fraises allemande parce qu'en fait elles
seront moins chers que les fraises
françaises et une bonne
si de fraises françaises ne sera pas
ramassé quand je parle que des fraises
alors que vous avez asperges et qui
arrive très vite les fruits les fruits
aussi est ce qu'aujourd'hui le monde
agricole
voilà repose essentiellement sur des
travailleurs étrangers et c'est pour
cela qu'on est dans cette dans ce
problème
oui de plaisance ont le monde agricole
repose sur le fait de travailler le
trajet et attention le monde agricole
qu'est ce qu'ils cherchent à diminuer
les coûts de production
parce qu'en fait on est on est dans une
concurrence intra-européenne qui est
très dur et on sait que le ces fameux
travailleurs détachés travailler dans
des grandes firmes allemandes beaucoup
moins cher que chez nous donc dans tout
ça on précarisent et les agriculteurs
les travailleurs tout ça pour arriver
finalement avec des toujours les mêmes
qui font des bénéfices et à dire les
supermarchés et les transformateurs
alors que le maillon de production n'est
pas protégé nous on avait demandé très
vite au niveau français de tester des
travailleurs français qui voulaient
aller sur les fronts parce que ça nous
aurait incité à aller là toute sécurité
sur les fermes de préparer sa très en
amont mais aujourd'hui tout se fait dans
l'urgence
et quand on voit que l'allemagne est
donc et l'autriche ont affrété les
avions pourront travailler des
travailleurs et immigrés nous on voit
très bien que derrière tout ça qui c'est
qui va payer les pots cassés sur les
producteurs parce que la grande
distribution va se tourner vers ce
produit la dernière question on se
souvient que la semaine dernière
emmanuel macron insisté sur le fait de
jeu si trop bâtir une indépendance
agricole une revendication des
agriculteurs que l'on entend depuis
longtemps et vous satisfait de cette
annonce du président de la république
écoutez je pense que je suis le premier
à être satisfait parce que nous la
coordination rurale depuis 1992 on parle
de souveraineté alimentaire
on avait vu qu'avec cette nouvelle pac
où on avait on devait produire une
alimentation saine de qualité et avec
des prix rémunérateurs
on a laissé des prix rémunérateurs de
côté et on a ouvert le libre marché
européenne aux 80 et nous de ce côté là
on a perdu plus de la moitié de nos
confrères agriculteurs parce qu'en fait
il a fallu s'adapter ou mourir et dont
beaucoup ont disparu
donc oui emmanuel macron est capable de
faire de très belles phrases il a fait
il l'a fait il avait déjà prononcé quand
il a fait les états généraux de
l'alimentation à régis mais derrière
c'est très belle phrase dans le monde
d'après il va falloir qui le singularise
je rappelle que
nous en tant que coordination rurale
nous estimons que l'agriculture est
d'ailleurs le ministre de l'agriculture
l'avait dit entre la santé c'est
l'agriculture et dans l'agriculture
c'est l'agriculteur n'imaginons pas que
nous allons avoir une souveraineté
agricole agricole sans agriculteurs et
donc ça c'est important aujourd'hui
parce que nous sommes tout juste 400
mille agriculteurs et si on ne veille
pas à me protéger
demain l'alimentation ne sera plus
française merci beaucoup
bernard lannes d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
président de la coordination rurale
merci